Good morning folks. Welcome back.
Pleasant Saturday to you. As you can
see, the market is closed and we have
a lot of questions that was given to me.
I now obviously I can't answer all of
them. So, I kind of like curated a a
list of them and others are actually
answered. If you just go through the
rest of the videos, some of the
questions were obviously by new readers,
viewers, students, casual, you know,
inquiries. I don't really satisfy casual
inquiries uh simply because I spent a
lot of my personal time creating the
lectures on this YouTube channel. So if
you don't want to take the uh time and
the initiative to kind of like
investigate it and go through the
content, I don't feel obligated to save
you any time. I've spent enough of my
own time to save you a lifetime. So I
want to kind of talk about something and
a topical study and it is a week in a
life cycle of price and again this is
for Saturday's weekend lecture and it's
August 15th 2026
and what you're looking at here is a
weekly chart of the NASDAQ composite
index. Now, this is a continuous
contract, okay? So, [sighs] I'm going to
go through and
I'm going to be answering questions.
Some of the questions I want to make
sure that you know I'm addressing, I'll
specifically refer to and others will
just simply because you're watching the
content, you'll see that you're your
answer basically is being supplied.
Okay? So, uh, just know that my analysis
always begins with a continuous
contract. I actually use a monthly
chart, but I don't need to do that today
cuz I'm going to actually ring in the
monthly highs and monthly lows. So, that
way it'll be helpful for you.
Speaking of which, this is the NASDAQ
Composite Index continuous contract
chart on the weekly time frame, as you
can see right up here.
And the high of July is represented by
this weekly candle. And the low of July
represented by this candlestick's low.
Okay. So by having that range defined,
what I'm going to be looking at on the
continuous contract is how does the
daily contract front month, for
instance, we're trading the September
delivery contract for NQ or NASDAQ
futures.
Does it show an agreement with levels
that would be
arrived at by using the continuous
contract? Continuous contract gives me a
a field of reference for key highs, key
lows, inefficiencies,
uh arrays that may not actually occur in
the front month because of the rollover
effect that this capitalizes on. So the
continuous contract aids in that regard.
Whereas the front month contract that
will expire,
it starts trading at a time when its
influence over this composite charting
application of a continuous contract
chart doesn't help. It doesn't have any
input in it. Okay? Because it's so far
down the line that of
future contracts trading in the future.
Like for instance, March of 2027, it's
having no impact on this composite
charting of a continuous contract.
December isn't having any impact on this
either. But by referring back to old
price data,
it allows me to look at things where the
average person wouldn't. Okay? So,
there's times, and I recently taught
this this year, so go back and look at
the lectures, all part of this playlist,
the 2026 lecture notes playlist on my
YouTube channel. uh I I go extensively
into certain things that I'm looking for
that are only going to be derived by
looking at a continuous contract chart,
not just simply the futures contract
that's traded front month or nearby.
If you are a CFD trader, in other words,
if you're outside the range of trading
US futures markets or let's say this
way, if you're not able to participate
in that in your area or geographic in
the in the globe and you're trading with
CFDs,
you'll be using the same concept here.
Okay? You're just simply going to be
utilizing the continuous contract here
and then blending the actual highs and
lows for the individual days or weeks.
Look for its
closest correlated high and low on your
weekly chart for the CFD US 100 or if
you're trading the SPOS, it's the US 500
or the equivalent thereof. Okay? So, I I
can't scratch everybody's itch. Okay?
And I I'm not gonna I tried in the past.
I tried very hard to to try to
accommodate every single person that
comes to me and what market they want to
follow. And basically, you're asking me
to be your AI assistant. And I'm I'm not
going to do that. Okay? Everything that
I'm doing here in one market, one market
that allows me to focus, spend my time
economically where I can still teach.
And then you can take this information
and transpose it to the markets that you
trade. Everything I'm showing you here
works in Forex. Everything in here works
in gold, everything in here works in
commodities, it works in bonds, it works
in
whatever, okay? Whether you're using the
CFD market or the futures contracts, it
it doesn't matter. It's the same thing.
Okay? So, what I'm giving you is is a
workshop today and hopefully in about a
half an hour or so
compressing all the things that you
would do. Okay? And this is what helps
get a bias. This is what helps to
determine where I think the market's
going to go after we open at 9:30
Eastern time on regular trading hours.
How I look for pools of liquidity. What
pools of liquidity am I interested in?
How to differentiate which ones are
strong? Which
highs and lows do I ignore? Because
obviously I teach you to draw towards
that with your objective and reading
price going forward.
That's like a targeting method. So what
about when there's relative equal highs
there? When do I disregard those? All
these things are going to be answered in
this lecture. Okay, just because I'm
going to compress it down to a small
amount of time, don't discount it that
there must be more. It's just a matter
of experience and you'll see what I mean
by that. So we have a range here defined
by July's high and low. It's not
complicated, is it? No, it's not. And
we're going to continue with that. And
we're going to go in. And then look at
this guy. He's always got to creep
around. Show his face. Look. I think
he's attention seeking, isn't he? Look
at him. Beady little eyes.
So anyway, we're going to roll into
the weekly chart zoomed in. So now we
have the previous week's high. That's
this right here. And the previous week's
low. And again, we're still dealing with
the continuous contract.
By having these levels here, we already
come to a great deal of information.
We're inside of a new week when we're
trading right here. We opened right
there. Now, where do you think the
market's likely to go to if we're
opening right here on the present week
we just closed? Okay, so it's Saturday
when we opened up on Sunday. If we
opened on Sunday and we're right here,
is it more likely? This is for the bias
seeking questions. This is for the
direction, the draw liquidity. How do
you determine the draw in liquidity? How
do you get the uh the draw in liquidity
so accurate, Michael? How do you how do
you know how to feel confident to post
these things on the internet beforehand
and then they go to these levels? I'm
showing you. So, if we're opening here,
is it more likely that we're going to go
to the previous week's high or the
previous month's high versus from this
opening all the way down to previous
week's low or previous week I'm sorry,
previous month's low.
Clearly, it's easier to get to it here.
So, this is the path of least
resistance. It's also part of a primary
bullish market.
And they keep propping this market up.
And you can argue about whatever you
want to call it, but it's artificial.
Okay? The market should not even be at
these levels. The economy is not good.
The the the fear and trepidation of
investing you large sums of money with
this administration and everything
that's going on around it. All the data
that comes out is all fake. Okay? All
this fundamental data fake. So
sticking with the, you know, the
narrative that continuously moves
forward being a bullish market
until proven otherwise, we got to still
take this bullish order flow for what
it's showing us. It wants to keep
pressing higher. So that's how we open
up this week, looking for the previous
week and previous month's high to be
traded to. Now,
there's always going to be people that
see that and say, "Oh, well, you know,
of course you it's going to likely do
that." But that's what I'm answering.
I'm answering the question to students
that are asking, "Why do I think a
specific draw in liquidity is paramount
or more likely to deliver to that of
something else?" Okay, this is what I'm
doing every single week. every single
week soon as Friday's close. Either I'm
waiting until my family falls asleep or
I'll do it like on like today, Saturday.
And I do it real early in the morning. I
get my analysis and scribble my little
notes on my little notepad here. And
everything that's on my notepad, I'm
sharing here today. Okay. So, these are
all the things that I went through. um
the the thought process this week and I
can show where I said certain things
that week you can prove and hold me to
the fire. Okay. So now we have that
range defined
the same bit of business. Okay. This
blue line here is just so I can line up
these things here. My
obsessivecompulsive
part of the ICT character which isn't
real. The uh it's flaring because I know
you're probably going to think what's
this what's that blue line there? Are
you predicting something? No, I'm just
drawing a line for reference. That way I
can drag this point out and this point
out where you both I'm sorry. These both
can be read easily, but where I draw
this one to an end, this one I want to
kind of like match it up and I just
didn't take that blue line out. Okay, so
there I promise you there's nothing um
mystical about it. I'm not predicting
anything. Don't come back and say, "See,
he was trying to tell you something." I
wasn't. Okay, it's just simply leaving
leaving an artifact in the video that
should have been edited out. So, that's
that. So, now we're going to take our
attention over to the actual futures
contract for September delivery. And I
already done the work for you.
[snorts and laughter]
And there's the high for July. So,
that's the monthly high. And here's the
monthly low for July. And then we have
previous week's low and previous week's
high. See that? Now, with these levels
here, same bit of business when we
opened up on September deliveries
contract month for NQ or NASDAQ futures,
is it more likely that it was going to
come all the way back down and take out
previous week's low or previous month's
low or take out previous week's high and
or July's high? Clearly, it's so close
to it. Just static price action alone is
likely to send us up in there. Okay,
even if it were to go up there and
somehow next week, you know, we crashed
and went lower. I'm not suggesting that
we're going to do that. I don't know
what we're going to do yet. Okay, I have
to see where we're going to open up on
Sunday, let it trade through Sunday, and
watch the opening range on Monday. Okay,
that's what I'm submitting to.
It's more likely to see it go to those
levels simply based on that. Now, that's
enough of a range to do very, very well.
Don't look at this r previous week and
say, "Oh, look at this little tiny
little move. He's calling that a big
like it's a big deal. Well, it is a big
deal when you're doing it every single
week in front of the public all the time
over and over and over again using the
things I'm teaching you here. So, it's
important for you to pay attention to
how simple the things are,
but you look at the number of videos and
the
the amount of speaking points that I
give because I'm answering thousands of
questions that come to me over time. And
sometimes when they're really good
questions, I'll have a notepad that I
have when I touch on this subject, make
sure you bring up this too because I I
see a number of people asking around
that same premise or theme of a
question. So I'm kind of always getting
to the point eventually for you, but I
still have to stay in a schedule that
I'm comfortable with because I'm
following the path of how I developed
all these things in the order of their
creation. Okay? So,
nobody's going to disrupt that order.
And once it's done, then it's it's done.
So, we're going to drop down into a
daily chart. Those same levels are
transposed here. Okay. So, we have
previous month and previous week high
and low annotated here. And I'm going to
take your focus into a couple different
things of last week's trading. And we
won't need to worry about this previous
week's low. And we won't need to worry
about the previous month's low. So that
that's not something that we need to
concern ourselves with at the moment.
But if we go out to a daily chart, I
want to get a couple reference points
here. And again, we're using the
September delivery contract month for
NQ.
And when price was sitting in here, so
we have Friday, Thursday, Wednesday,
Tuesday, Monday, and last Friday's
close. Okay. So last Friday's daily
range is here. Thursday, Wednesday's
high here.
If it were to take that out, what above
that last week's high or previous week's
high, what would be a PD array or PD
arrays plural, what would be a likely
candidate or candidates they could reach
for? Well, immediately this is over here
and we talked about this. This is too
smooth. Okay, real real smooth. The
market doesn't like to keep those types
of things there. So they want to make it
jagged. So in this case, we went through
it here on Thursday and cut all the way
through these candles before we get to
this high. Okay? Because that's what
classic support and resistance would
say. Well, if it takes out these highs
here, that's resistance broken. And then
if it continues going higher, what's the
next reference point for resistance?
That high.
Well, before we get there, we got to cut
through the chaff.
Oh, right there. Sell something. You
like that? Only the highest form of
production
around here. Bump. You hear that? I
don't have to have I don't have to push
a button for that. Bump.
Southside and bounce by. I need a dad
jokes. They just that just keep rolling
in, don't they?
I don't know where it comes from. And my
wife looks at me all the time like she
is now with the hair guy. Like, really?
You're look you're you're doing that
right now. Yes, honey. I'm doing it just
like this. Okay, that's what got me
here. So, we have the low of this
candlestick here and the high of this
candlestick. So, that's the cibby sell
side of bounce by side in efficiency.
And it's an inefficiency when we cut
through candles because that's what the
algorithm is going to do. That doesn't
exist. That's what the buying and
selling pressure is going to most likely
agree on when it when you go through
these types of things. So, we also have
this wick. says it's a premium wick when
we're here and then the next day we open
and I'll get to all these levels here in
a moment but it's going to likely trade
up to previous week's high which I gave
you tweets about and then if it goes
that higher it's going to clean these
relative equal highs and if it keeps
going higher then we have this wick
which is a premium wick what makes it a
premium because on
Wednesday's trading and close we're
below below it still. So if it's going
to go higher, that's a premium array.
It's treated just like a gap just like
this is. And then we have this
inefficiency. So by grading these wicks
like this, we get consequent
encroachment and the market trades right
up there. Look at the open. Isn't that
crazy? That's pretty insane, isn't it?
Okay, who would have thunk it? I know
it's not a real word, but hey, it is
what it is. Or is it? I don't know. I
got to check it after this video now.
Dunk it.
It's probably been added as like a um
See how easy it is for me to get off
topic? I do this on purpose because I
know people like to complain in the
comment section. You're the worst
teacher in ever been and you can't stay
on topic. I know how to stay on topic. I
just do this to filter out the people
that are just here for the easy stuff.
You want the cookies and milk at the
beginning. No, you got to have the meat
first. So, we have a buy sign bounce
sign efficiency here on the daily chart.
We have a volume and bounce at the low.
We don't have a volume of bounce at the
high. And then the market trades down
into that last week, rallies up, and
then we started consolidating. Okay. So,
when do retail bull flags form and
they're trustworthy?
Oh, this is blasphemy. ICT is talking
about
retail bull flags.
Well, everything I said about where
we're at in relationship to the previous
week's high and previous month's high
and the likelihood of it going there
versus the previous week's low or
previous month's low
holds true here. So, that would validate
this as a potential bull flag. It could
go higher. Now, I'm not saying it's
going to go from the full flag pole of
it. it's going to go up there because if
it does that then it's going to push us
into these relative equal highs which I
mentioned this week and then potentially
another all-time high. I'm not going to
go so far as to say that. I I don't want
to I don't want to say that yet. Okay.
So, just know that we got to take one
thing at a time, one PDA at a time. So,
there are several things multi multiple
things really that led to me
anticipating the market likely trading
higher. Okay. So now going forward,
continuing on,
we have
return back into the daily chart zoomed
in. So we have that buy side and balance
sell sign efficiency that's shown here
that just showed you moments ago when we
were zoomed out. And we have previous
month high and previous week high here
annotated. And I want to just focus on a
few things here. Very little annotations
on the chart.
with the chart kind of crushed in
horizontally so that way that the
candlesticks look a little bit more
uniform. We have the buy side and
balance sell sign efficiency
and notice that when this retracement
occurred last week, not the week we just
closed. Okay, so this was Friday,
yesterday, Thursday, Wednesday, Tuesday,
Monday, last Friday, last Thursday.
Okay, that's what this is here. So, when
it traded down in this inefficiency,
that's this buy sign bell sell sign
efficiency on the daily chart. I always
keep referring back to the time frame
I'm showing up here. Okay,
this low doesn't touch. So, it failed to
gladand with the consequent
encroachment. Gladhanding is where
there's pairing of orders and it allows
to book or print at a specific price
level. If it can't do that when this
array forms initially when this forms it
means that okay if the market's bullish
the upper half which would be this
candlestick's low down to it consequent
encroachment or midpoint that's where
the bullish buyside
order flow coming in like markets uh the
buyers okay for smart money purpose will
want to be buying in that portion of
this gap. Okay,
it is the strongest when you see these
types of things where the runs start in
the upper half and they start to run
higher. That's confirming bullish order
flow. No gimmicks required. All in the
open, high, low, and close of the
candlestick. Very simple stuff. It's
free to see it.
If it can't even touch consequent
encroachment, it really is bullish,
especially on the heels of it not laying
any bodies or burying any bodies below
consequent encroachment.
So there's no unfinished business down
here because a bullish market should
have inefficiencies left open. And I'm
the first person to ever teach that
concept. And so many people say, "Oh,
that's always been around." No, it
hasn't. No, it has not. So, it rallies
here with bullish order flow as I teach
it. Not level two, not depth of market,
doms, footprint. We don't need any of
that stuff. Okay? If you want to use
that stuff,
if it agrees with what I'm teaching,
then it'll work. And that sounds very
narcissistic, doesn't it? But that's
just the facts, Jack. So, it rallies out
of that. And then look what we're doing
here. The Tuesday, I'm sorry, Thursday,
the Friday of last week. And then Monday
we open below this candlesticks close
which is rejection block. So we're we're
creating this like little area where
it's just simply saying I'm not willing
to go above that. Why? What's going on?
I'll get to that. I'll get to that.
Don't worry. But it trades softer on
Tuesday. Now look what's happening here.
This right there.
Look what it's doing. More specifically,
look what it's not doing. the low of
this candlestick here failed on Tuesday
to trade to the buy side of balance sell
side and efficiency high which was this
candlestick's low. So let's take a
closer look at it. So on this day here
on Thursday, how can we know this is
going to be a large range day?
Because it's the end of the big
impactful news. It's the PPI number and
it's part of a day where we're closing
in on the on the the last day or day
before final trading day of the week
which is Friday.
And we hadn't really closed above
this rejection block yet.
all this consolidation in here and on
Tuesday we had this little tip off here
that they did not gladhand with the low
of this candlestick which is the high of
this buy center balance sign efficiency.
So we have two things, two themes, two
confirmations that bullish order flow is
still in order. That means if you want
to say it this way, I am predicting the
buying pressure.
If you if you want to look at it that
way, okay, wonderful. That makes me like
the trading crescen. I'm the
mindreading, you know, guru of uh I'm
the Dr. Xavier of price action. I'm able
to get in everybody's head with cerebral
um attacks where I can go in there and
cerebral putting my little helmet on and
I can read everybody's buying and
selling pressure minds. Okay, [laughter]
if you want to do that, that's fine.
I'll roll with that for a little while.
That's fine. But what's actually
happening is is the algorithm is going
to displace higher and be permitted to
trade into previous week's high,
previous month's high, and then in the
other PD race that I mentioned a moment
ago. But for now, we're gonna zero in,
okay, on a very specific thing that I
talked about. I said that Thursday,
which is being highlighted here, this
candlestick right there. You can all the
things I do online, you can always hold
my feet to the fire. Okay? I don't say
anything extra. Even though I do talk a
lot, I am the mentor with the mount. The
bottom line is is I always leave you
breadcrumbs
and I never delete anything. Ever. I
never edit a post where there's any kind
of specific key level or what I expect.
And here's a student here.
Do you think it's going to be a large
range day? Almost four small range days.
What's my answer there? I do.
I do. And this is occurring at 8:14 a.m.
on August 13th
before this run.
Okay. Before the PPI number comes out.
It's going to be a large range day. And
and I'm indicating here that I'm
anticipating a drop down to go up to
take out at least Wednesday's high.
Think about that. Think about that.
So,
if it's going to do these types of
things, I'm clearly indicating with no
uncertain u terms that there's going to
be
with very specific terms, no ambiguity.
I'm looking for higher prices. So, I'm
teaching by principle and theory that
I've already taught at Nauseium for
years how to determine the draw on
liquidity, how to determine the bias,
how to determine where the market's
going to go. And I'm giving you the
details as to why I felt inclined to be
so forward with it in the public eye.
Okay. So,
continuing on, we're going to drop down
into a 15-minute time frame. Okay. And
now when we go into a week, we want to
know what we're looking for. Okay? And
we want to look at like
in my private mentorship, there are
lectures that are taught in like month
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, all the way through
month 12 that are very very smart money
oriented concepts. They are literally
road maps that tells you what these
algorithmic moves are going to be like
and how to anticipate them. Okay. So,
when we look at for instance this the
entirety of the week viewed through the
lens of a 15-minute time frame. Why 15
minutes? Because it's a bell weather
time frame. It allows me to see
everything. It gives me the full weekly
range. If I scroll out a little bit, you
know, further and show last week's price
action, I can pick out very key levels
and determine where and sometimes
checking my notes because on on the
weekend, I always like to go back over
and say, okay, I wrote down previous
Monday's Asian session buy side
liquidity pool as a specific high and I
want to know what that level is. I want
to make sure I'm I wrote that down
because, you know, I'm human. I could I
could be distracted by my awesome wife.
She could walk by here, you know, coming
out, you know, letting the towel drop
down. You know, you know, you know it's
like, guys, you know what it's like,
ladies. Here's some hints for you. You
want a happy marriage. So, the point is
this. I want to go back through and see
where the points and pools of liquidity
are relative to sessions, okay? Not just
simply the daily highs and the lows
because obviously those are those are
very strong independent uh buy side and
sell side liquidity bulls but there's
also the high and low the last three
days there's also previous week high and
low and there's previous month high and
low okay but we can take it down
intraday into what was the Asian
sessions high and low
what was the London sessions high and
low
what is the AM session in New works
session high and low. Then you have the
2-hour window. That's the New York
lunch. What's the high and low of that?
Every time you get these ranges, you
want also know what the midpoint is.
Okay? So that midpoint, that's an
equilibrium price point. You also want
to know what they are, too. And that's
what's written on my notepad all the
time. Okay? And you see them very
clearly and visibly inside of a
15-minute time frame. It's all laid out
here perfectly for you. Okay? Um earlier
in the week I stated that my interest
was in the 29,984
price level. That's these relative equal
highs. That just so happens to be
Monday's London session by sell
liquidity.
And then after Monday's trading, I gave
a short little review and you can go and
look at the reviews, okay? Look at
everything I posted.
And I mentioned these relative equal
lows here. And I said it could
it could go down there and take that
sell side out. But I didn't mention
anything lower than that. Did I? No, I
did not. No, Siri Bob, that didn't
happen. Nothing edited, nothing
mentioned lower than that. That's
interesting. But now watch that daily
buy sell sign efficiency. See it? its
portion the upper portion of it right
here. Look what's happening there. You
can see that it's trading down but
falling short of touching that. Is that
bullish or bearish? That is absolutely
rockstar bullish.
Okay. Once these are taken out now in my
mind I'm thinking it could trade down
and touch that by bounce outside
efficiency. Okay. And that's why I left
no clear indication of how far it can go
through these lows with protraction. But
I gave you nothing lower than these
levels here. So what does that mean?
This is going to get swept. They're
going to take those lows while remaining
bullish
and it can't even touch that buy bounce
outside efficiency. That is awesome
bullish order flow. You don't need to
know how many people bought underneath
these lows. You don't need to know how
many people had a
number of orders executed. You don't you
don't need to know any of that stuff.
You don't need that. And then watch how
price rips higher. Okay? And uses this
good oldfashioned ICT bullish breaker.
Look at that. Handsomely now
rallies up. Goes into the inefficiencies
here. Trades there. Rallies. Where's it
going? Where could it possibly be
reaching?
Well, I'm going out on a limb here,
okay? It's dangerous. I got a saw in
hand. I'm sawing and I'm standing on the
the outer edge of this branch and I'm
sawing it off right now cuz I'm going to
say something that some of you are going
to think it's hindsight cherry picked. I
know. I know that's how you think about
it, but go back and look at what I gave
and then how the market delivered. Okay,
we have Monday's New York session AM by
side liquidity.
And yes, I read that out of order of the
text cuz I'm a rebel. Okay, but it
obviously said the same thing. But
there's also this right here. This is a
pool of liquidity for Tuesday.
What is that? That's Tuesday's I have it
highlighted down here for you. See that?
I'm saving you some time. That's
Tuesday's AM session
by South Kool. All right. So, what
you're trying to tell me is yes, it's
just that simple. Yes, Virginia, it does
not require a whole lot of acrobatics to
determine where key highs and lows were
the liquidity and the draw is going to
be at. It's based on session highs and
lows, previous highs and lows,
last three days, high and low. That
range is a dynamic range. It
continuously morphs and changes.
But then you have static
highs and lows which are session
oriented like what I'm showing you here.
And then the previous days highs and
lows and then you have the previous
week's highs and lows and the previous
month's highs and lows. And by comparing
where we're at in close proximity to
whatever those levels exist, the higher
the time frame, the more likely it's
going to draw to it. Because if it's
going to be a daily level like an old
high on a daily chart, there's going to
be a lot of institutional sponsorship
between where the market is right now
and it getting to those levels. Meaning
that it's got a like a rocket fuel
behind the likelihood of it moving in
your favor if you're expecting it to
trade there and go through it. Okay. So,
this creates relative equal highs, too.
So, when it took this out, it's
reasonable to anticipate this high and
then this high being taken out. But, but
look at this. Here comes the receipts
again. So, here's old ICT waking up.
Sand man's dusting his eyes still waking
up. Just sitting down saying, "Okay, I'm
going to tell the world what's about to
happen." And I type out 29,894.
Well, that's not useful because we're
you we're in close proximity to that
already. So, that was a a typo. Did I
edit that out? Nope.
Go look at that tweet. It's not edited.
And whenever I make a mistake typing,
because I am human, sometimes I'm a
little bit rushed for time because my
wife will say, "Hey, look, let's go do
this." Or, "Hey, can you do this?" Or,
"My son needs something." Or, "The dogs
are doing something." Something is going
on where I I have a thought in my mind
and I hurry up want to share it online.
So, I'm text messaging all of you on my
X feed. Basically, what I'm doing,
sometimes it doesn't come out right.
Sometimes autocorrect does something
that irritates me and it'll say
something like, you know, you know,
I don't know, it'll replace a word that
I didn't really want to say, but it's in
this case, you can see clearly that
there's no editing there. It's just me
coming right behind it saying no. 29,984
rather just woke up. Laugh out loud.
Okay. So, I'm
I'm reminding you that just because I
say a level, look at it and see if it
makes sense because I could have made an
error. I could have and just so happens
I caught myself there. But I'm never
really wrong about where it's going to
go to. And that's what I want you to
judge me on. Judge me on that. Okay? And
the context of just because I put a
level there, that means I'm interested
in that level for a specific purpose. I
want to trade it. I want to see a run go
to it. And you saw me do it this week
where to the 29,984
level.
Yes, right there.
Right on up into it. So, how about it?
So, the bottom line is this.
When it happens, you can see it here.
Here's my little thing bob. You can see
where the entry was. You can see it's
not market replay. You can see it going
right there. And there it is. Okay. So,
it's me showing you the level I'm
interested in and then me executing on
it using the information I teach. So,
it's proof of concept. It's proof of
visibility and foresight. It's not
ambiguous.
It's not ambiguous to some that's brand
new. You just think I'm just toss the
numbers out there. And that's what you
see all these these sock puppet
accounts. They'll come out or somebody
that's got a a larger um presence in the
industry. usually they're selling
something and they're very um
intimidated by me because I nobody can
influence me. Um I give away all of the
money-making opportunity of my brand
because I'm not capitalizing on it. I
don't take anything from anyone. You
can't do anything to me. You can't hurt
me. There's nothing you can do to hurt
me. But when these people create these
little sock puppet accounts and they go
online and they'll say, "Oh, I can do
that, too. I'll put a number out there
in the ether and eventually it'll get
hit and say, "See how smart I am." No,
you won't. You are not going to tell me.
This is why they don't ever do it. I'm
sure they probably do it in secret.
They're trying to do it. They never come
forward with it. Why is it me and my
students, we can always do this. Someone
throws a gauntlet down, says, you know,
do this, do this, do this. Okay, but and
there it is. You can see us executing.
You can see it from the beginning to the
end. Okay. And I'm so proud of all of
you. Not because I want you to be out
there, you know, arm wrestling these you
mental giants in their own mind with
their midgets. Really, the bottom line
is is I want you to just focus on your
own development. You know, after a
while, you get bigger and better at
knowing how to do all this stuff and you
want to get online sport with these
people. You know, it was a lot of fun,
but it gets old. You know, it's just the
novelty wears off.
But I'm giving you specific levels for a
purpose, okay? Okay, just like I gave
you the relative equal lows here and I
gave you this level here. Those were the
the benchmarks.
Okay, think of them like like bookends
or boundaries or perimeter lines that
the market is going to utilize until we
get to
CPI on Wednesday and then PPI on
Thursday. We're going to have to see
what we're going to see. You have to
wait and see what it's going to be like.
But there's going to be a bullish um
I had a bullish inclination thinking
it's going to go higher and I clearly
showed I showed that I I gave it out. I
told everybody very clearly that it was
my in my interpretation. I think that
market was going to go higher. Okay. So
while that's not signal service
providing type things, a lot of my
students understand that little nudge.
Okay, I'm going to focus on tape reading
the market going higher. Okay. And
right here it is. So what do where do
you go with this information and say
what did you use to get to this? Because
that's the question, you know, how did
you know that it was likely to do this
on the days that you say? Because how do
you know when it's going to do that? How
do you use the economic calendar? Well,
think about like this. The economic
calendar had the CPI on Wednesday and I
should have included the slide where it
had the the economic calendar. So in
your notes, pull up the calendar. Okay.
And uh you can be very helpful for me if
you are willing to do this. Go on to
last week that we just closed Monday
through Friday and pull up the medium
impact and high impact news events
and then post that picture right behind
this link on X. Okay. If you do that,
people that see the post and watch the
recording and whatnot, they'll have the
resource for them. I'm not going to do
it. I'm doing enough as it is. But at
least they'll be able to see like months
and years past, you know, when they look
at it in the future, some of you will be
helpful in this regard because they will
be able to look at this economic
calendar for this week. I just for the
sake of, you know, being human, I guess
I didn't think about until just now. I
should have included the the portion of
the economic counter showing you that
CPI was on Wednesday 8:30 Eastern time
and then EPI was at 8:30 a.m. Thursday
and then we had consumer sentiment
numbers and whatever they were medium
impact for Friday which is a nothing
burger really not they're not going to
do anything behind the heels of uh CPI
and PPI. So
let's take a look at what we can do now.
We're going to strip this down.
Now we're down to the chrome. Okay,
this is the entirety of the week
all the way up to Friday,
9:00 a.m. Eastern time. What did it do
at 9:00 a.m.? It took out this high.
See that? So, we had a rally up here,
consolidated,
rallied up. Okay. So, what day of the
week is this? You you have to know the
extraction point.
Okay. If you're going to be a sniper and
you're going to go into enemy lines and
you go out there and you're going to set
up your hide, okay, and you take your
shot, you take your markdown, and then
you got to know when to anticipate
the extraction.
Where are you supposed to be at when
you're leaving the marketplace? Where's
smart money going to leave? That's what
that's what I'm getting at. Where does
smart money leave
the theater of war
that started at Sunday at 6 p.m. Eastern
time and ends at 4:59
and going right to 5:00
Eastern time on Friday. Where where are
they exiting?
Where's their extraction?
Many times it's what I teach in terms of
TGI if thank god it's Friday. Okay, it's
just a little expression that when we
have bullish weeks usually the market
trades off from the high intra week and
settles somewhere around the 20 to 30%
of the weekly range. You can use this as
a trade idea. And I'm going to
illustrate something in a moment, but
for now, just know that once we take out
this high here and and it starts to
break down, soon as it breaks down and
takes out this low, notice again what
time frame we're on. 15 minute. It's a
bell weather. So, if you're going to be
doing reference points for TGIF, this is
a wonderful time frame to do it on. You
don't need to go any higher than this.
You'll see everything. You'll see the
whole entire lay of the land.
Look what happens. market trades down to
30%.
Weekly range and I divided it in half
just simply by using the the usefulness
of creating a 0.25 level. That's just
simply going to give me the mid midpoint
here. I'm personally interested in
getting to that level because we're in a
primary bull market. I felt very
strongly that we were going to take out
the relative equal lows here,
but I don't want to commit to the full
run of this buy side of balance sell
efficiency that's not highlighted. But
you can see the volume imbalance
to the high up here. And there may be a
volume imbalance in there, but I can't
tell. My my old eyes won't let me focus
on that. But main thing is there's an
inefficiency there that could lead to
lower prices. And I'm not looking for
that going against the primary bullish
manipulation of this market's been
presently under for a year or so or
more. And when we took out this low
there,
that means that these are likely to get
traded to. Why? Because the market is
very likely on Fridays when we have a
bullish week or a bearish week. It comes
off of its extreme. When it's been
bullish, it's going to trade off its
high and pull back into the weekly
range. That range being from here down
here to lowest one, which happens to be
that run below those relative equal
lows. Now, what did ICT show you again
this week? The weekly high and the
weekly low. Okay. Now, do I have to
always get in at the low and the high of
the week to take a trade on? No, I
don't. I don't have to do that. Okay.
Um, let's go and and add some more
detail.
For those that have not had the benefit
of going through the actual teachings
that I had when I was doing a paid
mentorship behind a payw wall, okay? I
had a whole legion of you all around the
world that came to me and I don't do
that anymore. And I know a lot of you
still ask and I think most of you it's
because you want me to create a market
for that so you can sell pirated
versions of it. Okay? I made
millionaires all around the world just
by them selling my stuff. Okay? And the
ones that did that and ran out of money
doing it that way, they just started
doing their own little mentorships and
pretending I don't exist. Okay, so
that's fine. Whatever. Whatever gets
your family fed. That's how I look at
it. So we look at this. This is the ICT
monthly mentorship
teachings from short-term trading model.
And I'm teaching in the latter months I
think if I'm not mistaken.
I think, please don't hold me to this
because I did all these things in 2017
and I know a number of you will know
exactly what month content it's from,
but check
month seven of the 2017 mentorship. I
think if I'm wrong, you it is what it
is. But it's either month seven or just
after that I go in and I start teaching.
It may be month six, but I don't know.
[laughter]
Look at month six playlist. look at um
somebody's going to obviously have the
um the actual
see this this is the part that makes me
poor as a as an educator as a teacher
cuz I I don't I don't have all that
information at hand simply because I'm
demanding all of you to have your own
due diligence in this. So again, you're
getting all this for free. I could have
been doing this paid mentorship forever
and people would still be buying it and
it is what it is. But I'm I'm not trying
to do that. Okay. So, do a little bit of
work. The leg work is pretty easy. Um,
and I'm sure the students will probably
come, Kit or someone else is probably
going to come in here in the comment
section and say, "Here's the video
you're going to look for on the YouTube
channel, and this is the minute marker,
probably where it's going to be shown,
and there it is." And and you'll be able
to say, "Thank you." And there it is.
But what am I getting at? I'm getting at
the fact that I was teaching weekly
profiles. Now, when you hear that word
profile, see, see, I told you he uses
market profile. No, I do not. Okay. I
profile the market before it even
trades, before your little market
profile gimmicks even populate that
little histogram of horizontal volume.
Before it even does that, I already have
a vision of what it's going to do, where
it's going to trade to, and how it's
going to trade there.
It's diabolical.
My wife's looking at me. Honey, you look
amazing. Let me just tell you right now.
[laughter]
When I'm done this, I want to take you
out and be seen in public with you,
okay? And I'm pissing some guys off
right now. I don't care. You're sing
after your wife, bro.
Anyway, listen. It's not an ICT video
unless I'm off the trail driving people
crazy. Okay, it's Saturday. Loosen up
already. Good grief. You're not missing
any trades. So,
what I covered here, I said, look at the
economic calendar. Look at what we
covered in the beginning of this video
with price where it's likely to draw to,
what it's not likely to do. It's not
likely to go down. It's not likely to
take out previous week's low. It's not
likely to take out
anything but buy side.
So, is that bullish or bearish? That's
bullish, baby. But now we have the
problem, the conundrum of
the economic calendar.
What days of the week
does the economic calendar fall on with
high impact news drivers? Well, it just
so happens it just so happens that on
Wednesday at 8:30 Eastern time, New York
local time, the CPI number was due out.
and you knew about this for months, just
like you know what they're going to be
for the next few months. Go look at the
economic calendar. Go project it
forward. You can plan this stuff ahead
just like you know when the Super Bowl
is going to be. You know, well, if
you're smart money, you know what teams
are going to be in the Super Bowl. Don't
say stuff like that, ICT. You can't
prove that. Well, [laughter]
listen. All I'm gonna say is look into
it, okay? They hint all the time. They
hint all the time before this season
even opens up. They put the colors out
there and the banner. You'll see it.
You'll see if you're looking for it.
Okay. So,
anyway,
they got to tell you what they're going
to do. And you have to believe
the witchcraft to fall for it. You can
deny it and not be a part of it. And
that's why I'm not in sports. Okay. So,
the idea, and they've done this with UFC
stuff, too. MMA, it's all rigged now. I
don't care what you say. Argue about it
and X with me. I don't care. So the
point is this. I have profiles,
okay? They're basically weekly
schematics on how the market will
deliver like a road map. This is
mapping. Okay? So when you're mapping,
what you're doing is you're anticipating
certain things to occur on specific days
of the week.
Now, think about what I just gave you in
terms of the economic calendar. Okay?
And we're having fun. I'm being silly
and whatever, but really dial in right
now, okay?
On Wednesday, we have CPI number that
came out just this past week. And I told
you
that price is going to have very
reasonable price swings that you can
trade on Monday and Tuesday. And then
Wednesday, the carnival ride begins at
8:30 and then it continues into Thursday
because PPI numbers going to come out
and then we have medium impact news
drivers for what? Friday. Now,
if we look at this little schematic that
was done in 2017,
an army, a legion, okay, a small nation,
[laughter]
come on now, were behind a payw wall
with me.
And probably many more people were
watching it all in leaked format,
okay? Willing to pay 10 bucks to some
goober. If you if you pay me 10 bucks,
I'll give you copies of it, too. That's
the way it was going on. That's what was
happening. And I was carrying all of you
on my back, baby. None of you took me
down. I'm still here.
I'm still here. That's right.
But they all were taught this.
Yep.
In the springtime and summer months of
2017, go ICT sat down. He parted the
books of market wizardry that was only
been written in by his pen and his
pencil on his pad.
And I shared a bit of logic with you.
This is what the market's going to do
visually in my brain. Okay? Because I am
Enigma. Enigma is talking to you. I am
explaining to you
what my algorithm will do.
I'm sharing with you how it's going to
happen.
And none of you really spend time in
those core content lessons because
you're intimidated by the length. You're
intimidated by the the the vastness of
the lectures, all the topics, because
you're afraid you're going to have
information overload. If you're going in
there to try to use it right away,
that's exactly what you're going to
suffer.
But when you ask me questions like, "How
do you know that the market isn't going
to go down and take out those relative
equal lows? Why didn't it go down and
take out the sell side from the previous
Asian market? Why didn't it do this? And
why how did you feel confident it was
going to do this?" And and why did you
pick this? And why'd you expect it to do
that? And what made you bullish on this
week? And what what
it's all in the core content.
You have to go through it one time.
And then the questions that come up by
going through all that, then the
learning really begins. But you have to
be familiar with it. And you're not
going to remember everything when you go
through it one time. Okay? You're not
because it's literally 30 years of
things crammed into videos that you
think is already too long, but there is
nobody else out there in the world
telling you with any discipline. Okay.
Find tell me what where is this in woff
where is this in order flow where's this
in anything else the market's going to
start here rally up create an important
low on Wednesday and then what happens
what happens what happens
it rallies
into the close of the week why because
something's going to occur in Tuesday's
crossover into Wednesday
that there is something bullish.
I already outlined the technicals.
I used the economic calendar to frame
this is how the market's going to trade.
Look, look what it's done.
Look at it.
Just like that. And this profile is
consolidation midweek rally.
Is that complicated?
If you're brand new, it would seem so.
But for the folks that's been here for a
little while, been here for a couple
years, you're you're looking at this
thinking that was there all the time.
Yeah. You're going to swear I edited
those videos. You're going to swear I
edited those videos from 2016, 2017.
Every single week it's doing the things
I taught every single week. Every single
week I'm coming out here on Twitter
where nothing's edited and nothing is
deleted and you all get to watch me use
it.
And that's why I'm challenging all of
you. When you hear these people, they
always come. They'll say, "Oh, he
rebranded." Find this in anything.
It's not anywhere else. It's not. It's
not there. [snorts]
But they hope that your short attention
span, you'll latch on to that and say,
"I believe that this guy's a scammer.
It's just too good to be true.
All you got to do is spend some time
with me. Just spend some time with me
and Mr. Wizard will blow your socks off
every single week because it's not going
to stop working. It's not going to fade
away. It's not going to become the
retail of trading. It can't it cannot
become the insufferable lunacy of retail
stuff.
Think about it. Look at all the other
things outside of what I'm teaching.
Everybody's clamoring that order flow is
the thing. Volume profile is the thing.
No, it's supply and demand. It's trend
lines. It's moving average crossover.
It's GAN. It's
whatever.
Who's right among all them?
None of them.
None of them are right.
When they make money, they're in
agreement with what I'm telling you.
That's the constant. Me, my logic, my
algorithm.
That's just the simple facts. You can't
argue. I'm literally providing it to you
in a public forum every single week. Why
are you sitting on the fence still? Why
are you doubting? Why aren't you in here
studying? You're robbing yourself of the
joy of being good at this in the amount
of time that your body and mind and
framework and disposition would permit
you to learn it. Well, you're the one
holding it back. Nobody else. I've
already taught these things, but you're
simply just not willing to put the
things to task because I told you it's
going to be hard. And you want somebody
to come out here and be the white knight
and say, "I watched all the ICT's videos
and I've condensed it down to five
minute trainers. Forget everything else
and just focus on this." And what they
just do told you was that's the thing
that resonated with them the most. and
you're going to try it and you're not
going to know all the other supporting
things that they they've learned, but
they're not going to ring into it
because they want you to subscribe to
their channel and they want you to
subscribe to their mentorship and you
you going to be end up paying for them
to talk to you. Every single person
that's a student of mine that's ever
said ever said, "I'm never going to be
doing mentorship. I'm not interested in
that." They all started mentorships.
Why? Because it's easy money.
It's easy money. It's really easy to
sell people the idea that they know
something that you don't know.
And I'm going to tell you something.
Many people out there claim to know
something they don't know. And there
ain't nobody else out there like me
that's coming out here every single week
and proving it to you for free and
enjoying it while I'm doing it. I'm
trying to encourage you. I want to
encourage you to dig into the things
I've spent my entire life formulating,
deciphering, receiving directly from the
Lord. Whether you want to believe in him
or not, I don't care. I don't care. But
that's the facts.
And yet these things keep hitting every
single week. I'm not talking about a
thousand different things and then look
look throw everything against the wall.
Whatever sticks, point to that. See, see
where I was right there?
That's what common sense will show you
that I'm not doing that. I'm calling out
very specific things and then I'm using
it with executions.
And that's why you don't see anybody
else, no detractor coming out and
saying, "Oh, he's using this, that, and
I think he's rebranded it." And I could
do that, too. And they never come
forward with anything. I always
challenge them all the time because I
know they can't do it. They can't do it.
They can't.
I'm literally walking you through the
process of knowing what the weekly highs
and lows are going to be by experience.
You're not going to learn how to do that
just by watching my videos. You're not
going to have some little trainer video
created by somebody else who can't even
do what I'm doing. They're not going to
be able to teach it to you. They're not
going to be able to teach it to you
because you have to go through the
process of using parts of this
information here and parts of this
information here. and experience will
guide you about this and other things.
And there's other weekly profiles in
here that talk about very specific
generic formulations of how the price
action will react,
what it's going to do, how's it going to
behave.
You need to go through those lectures.
You're asking me to teach you something
that I put lots of time and stress into
making sure it was useful information in
a condensed manner where it's user
friendly.
It doesn't feel that way because you're
trying to watch 15 videos on a weekend
binge watching it
and that's not the way you want to do
it. So anyway,
finish this up real quick. So we have
the one minute time frame. So we're at
the end of the week now. Okay, we're up
in that premium inefficiency from the
daily chart I showed you. And
right away, we're entering into the last
bit of business for Friday's morning
session, opening range. And there's the
opening price. So, regular trading hours
starts at 9:30 Eastern time. And right
here, it's Friday. We've rallied up. We
hit several targets on the upside.
It's likely to go into TGIF, which is
retrace back down into the weekly range,
20 to 30%. That's what this level is
here. 20% of the weekly range and 30% of
the weekly range. Okay. So, rough
eyeball it here about halfway. That's
about right in this area right there.
Okay. And it'll make sense in a moment,
but drawing towards previous month's
high. Not because it's support
resistance. Not because of that. No, no,
it's because of its 20 to 30% of the
weekly range.
Okay? So, I'm again, I'm not trading
support and resistance. You're going to
lose money trading that stuff. You don't
know what support and resistance the
market's going to say, I am going to
validate that one. I'm going to respect
that one. You don't know that. I know
which PDA raise it's going to be. I know
which liquidity pools. I'm proving it to
you every single week. Every single
week, week after week after week for
years, folks, for years.
I got students all the way back to 1996
still watching and they're laughing.
They're saying that all the time, send
me little emails, send me little
messages. Some of them have my personal
phone number like most of you and you
you all abuse it, okay? And that's why I
don't respond to you. But I have long
long-term students that'll reach out and
be like, "It's still crazy to see how
this stuff works all the time, even with
all this chaos." Yep. Because it's the
market. It is the source code. And
there's nobody out there that can take
that away or challenging it. it wouldn't
it won't happen because my stuff doesn't
fail. My stuff is sound logic. It's
codified. It's out there where you can
see it and weigh against the things I
taught and watch what the market does.
What I just showed you in this lecture
here, you need to be doing this every
single week. Go through those weekly
profiles every single week. Categorize
what is the week? What was the week that
just closed? I guarantee none of you are
doing that. None of you are doing that.
And then you wonder why you don't see
things in the future based on what
you've seen in the past. Because if
there is an algorithm or if there is a
rhyme and reason to the reoccurrence of
cycles of buying and selling pressure
silly that sounds that sounds silly. You
got to be a religious nut to believe
something like that versus it's rigged.
It's an algorithm and there it is.
I don't know why you guys are fighting
that. Everything in this world is ran by
AI right now. Everything. They're
literally going to have the military
making decisions now with AI. Think
about that. There's no algorithm running
this market here, this big casino, this
big Ponzi scheme. There's no way they
would use an algorithm doing that. No
way. No way, dude. No way.
When they started the circuit breakers,
that was the first threshold they were
bringing in to
bring artificial controls to it.
And then it became obvious that oh yeah
um nobody complained about that when
market should be allowed to crash.
If things are bad you should be able to
get out. You should be able to sell it
at a high and ride it all the way down
because it's a dead vehicle.
We don't have free markets, folks. We
don't have that. We have a Ponzi scheme.
They keep fluffing up. Okay. every week
there's some kind of excuse to fluff it
up to keep the illusion that the economy
is strong because the market's up and
it's not it's not doesn't equate
but it's th it's Thursday crossing over
to Friday registering hours now starting
up on 9:30 Eastern time on Friday
morning right here okay and if TGIF is
going to occur it's going to likely draw
down minimum right here this this right
lend
to 30% of the weekly range. That's
interesting because that would take it
down to previous month's high and
previous week's high and trade into
previous week's range. it goes down to
30.
That means that the opening price at
9:30,
if we rally above that power three
concept that I teach, which is how the
range high and range low is formed,
what range am I referring to? 9:30 to
10:00, the high is going to form
somewhere in between there.
What? I know. I know. It sounds crazy.
That sounds crazy, I know, but the
market rallies up. Now, if you're going
to be met with relative equal highs
because we have a high real close to
that, this is how you this is how you
manage this, okay? Because now you're
going to encounter guarded
buy side.
How do you know when they're not going
to take out relative equal highs? I see
you many times you're shortening when
there's relative equal highs there. What
makes you buckle your seat belts, baby?
We have a macro time. They don't believe
in that. They don't think it happens.
But 9:50 to 10:10. Okay. 9:50 to 10:10.
That's a big one. Why? Because it's
during the first hour of trading, the
first hour's dealing range. And it's the
close of the opening range, which is 30
minutes long. I don't care what anybody
else tells you. Okay.
It makes a high here. And now we're
pulling back to the 9:30 opening price.
It could very well rally up during the
macro and take out that high and that
high. So I want to see if they're going
to guard that.
If they guard it during the macro,
during the time 20 minutes, you're not
going to get the best best fill. You're
not going to get it because you're being
met with a challenging
issue here. It could take those highs
out, sweep, and then go lower. I'm not
in the business trying to go out there
and take losses. I that my goal is not
to live through the losses and still be
able to come out ahead. That that when
I'm looking at the market, I'm not
looking at that.
Retail trains you to think that way. It
conditions you to think, well, losing
60% of the time still can be profitable,
so aim there. I don't teach that. Now,
can individuals with 40% accuracy strike
rate, can they make lots of money? Yes.
But you got to be very, very good at
managing money, you got to be very good
at managing yourself in the model. And
you have to be comfortable with taking
lots of strikes across the chin and
getting knocked out a lot. I just don't
want to go through that. So my whole
life's pursuit has been focusing on
things where I could filter out
processes that lead to those things and
primarily focus on avoiding
the problem areas because that's a wide
chasm that nobody has done any work in
because there's a real deficiency in
there. Everybody can write a book and
say this is what I did to make money or
this is the stuff I saw in hindsight and
this is what looks like it works.
I trailblazed and said, I want to go
through and see what I have lost real
money with and then replaced that with
logic that says this is what the chart
usually tells you before you fall into
this trap.
And you don't find that in off you don't
find it in Elliot wave. You don't find
it in everything else they say I
rebranded. I am the only one out here
saying to everybody else, you're all
wrong. And I have the receipts to prove
it every week, every day, and it won't
stop. This relative equal high. I want
to see it take out
that 9:30 closing, I'm sorry, opening
price on a closing basis right here.
It does it right there. Now we have high
lower high lower high on a Friday where
TGFI can form. We have relative equal
lows that's not showing over here but I
show you only on the 15-minute time
frame and the likelihood of a draw down
to 20% of the weekly range. the highest
high that formed on the week,
we're likely to see what
a breakdown. If we go into this range,
which is the low here
all the way up to that high, that's 948.
I'm doing you the
service of if I'm reading that right. I
think it's 48. [laughter]
I got to find out how to make these
numbers down here bigger. if you know
how to make it bigger down here on the
time axis and over here I think it's
just the text setting size isn't it? I
think so. Um anyway
the high here at 948 and the low right
there I'm measuring that and I'm
greeting it with the fibs. So I'm
putting the octant levels and the
quadrant levels on. I'm not highlighting
the highest high and the lowest low.
That's what's missing. But everything
else is here. Okay. And this is the
midpoint or consequent encouragement. If
you look real close, look real real
close.
See what's happening here? We have this
buy side of balance sell sign
efficiency. Okay? Right before that
rejection block gets taken out.
You ask for these questions and don't
complain about the answers. Okay? It's
going to require you to know some
things. Rejection block, bro, why ain't
you talking about uh mitigation blocks?
I am
I'm just not calling every bit of
attention to them every single time they
come up. But this rejection block right
here is the highs up close. We go up to
it and we can't lay a body's close above
it. That's what a rejection block does.
Go look at month four content. Okay, I'm
teaching the PD raise there. [sighs]
If it does that, I'm getting a check in
the box that says, "Okay, now we're
starting to see it likely to be
failing." Then does the market come back
and overlap over top of this buy side of
bounce, sell side of efficiency, which
becomes a inversion of fair value gap.
If this is in fact going to fail and go
lower, I want to see it prove it with
this candlestick right here. It opens,
trades up, can't touch the high of it,
closes lower, outside of it. Is that
bullish or bearish?
The way I teach order flow, that baby is
bearish. Bearish. And now it's also
silver bullet time, baby. But not to be
outdone.
[laughter]
We have high low. They took out a low.
Model 2022, baby. I don't get any trades
in model 2020 because you don't know
what you're doing and you haven't
backtested enough until you get sick of
being able to see it happening all the
time
in the future because you watch so much
of it in hindsight. You shouldn't be
trying to trade.
You should not be trading if you don't
know for certain how your model is going
to form today. I know all my models and
I know the ones that are more prone to
form in any given day.
Certain models are just not going to do
it. They're not, you know, for like for
instance reversal models. If it's a
continuation trading environment, that's
not that's not something I'm going to go
for. Not to say that I can't go down to
a 15-minute time frame or a five minute
chart or 15-second chart and use that
model when I'm bullish to wait for a
reversal going at some low or
inefficient. then it works like that.
But I'm not saying that every model,
every single model I have works every
single day. And that's not because it
fails. It's because the conditions are
not ripe for that model to excel in.
It's kind of like when when you go to a
dentist, okay, or a doctor, they have
all kinds of instruments. All these
instruments, they're they all have a
primary function
and there's a tool for every procedure.
And I have a model that matches market
conditions because of my experience. I
know how to match really good models for
very specific market conditions based on
what I think the weekly profile is going
to be for it. Again, that is the
schematic of how the delivery is going
to happen across several days before
price has ever been printed yet
on the weekend before the market even
opens up at Sunday. I'm looking at those
profiles and mapping out how the
economic calendar could lead to my PDA
race delivering in concert with when the
economic report delivers these high
impact news drivers. How it would build
these profiles, the squiggly little
lines that I've given you in 2017.
It there isn't a large group of them
like you have to choose from. When
you're bullish, there's only so many you
form. And then look at how they form in
the graphic depiction. And how does that
match the economic calendar? Oh my
goodness. You're telling me, yeah, it's
just that simple, baby. All you see now
is ones and zeros. Welcome to the
matrix. So
it breaks below the inversion fair
value.
Confirms it right there. In the next
candlestick here, because I'm up against
those relative equal highs, I just want
to have a little bit more behind me. I
just want to have a little bit more.
So, I wait and see. This one here does
the same thing. We trade up to it. Gives
up the ghost. Comes back down. Well, now
I'm comfortable. I'm comfortable with
that. And there's a small little gap
right in here. It's a fair value gap,
but it's a suspension block. Okay. I'm
looking at that. And I'm also looking at
this wick over here. Why am I looking at
that? Because there's a gap here. and to
the left of that, the longest wick, my
focus is there. If I can be trading as
close as I can to about half of that,
even if I don't get in at this fair
value gap, because I I just want to be
in it now, I know it's likely to happen.
I know that I got to have at least a
stop that goes up to consequent
encouragement here. So, I'm going to go
with two contracts. You see me doing
larger uh position entries on that. But
because the stop, it kind of warrants me
only using two contracts.
So it rolls over. Look where the body's
Look at that. The body's right there at
consequent encouragement of that
suspension block that's bearish. This,
my friends, right there is the classic
ICT silver bullet that supposedly
doesn't exist anymore because they
changed the algorithm.
Come on. The old man's killing you. It's
like I'm throttling you every week.
Every time you say something, it doesn't
work anymore. I'm coming out here and
show. And I know some think, "Oh,
anybody could do this. Anybody can make
this up after it happens." I know. Hold
your horses. Sucks. Hold your for hold
your horses. Okay. Once we take out this
low, okay, once we take this low out,
which we do here,
and then we have this drop down.
Wonderful. The next candle, we open up
and we trade and create this wick. And
then we stop right here. half of that
consequent encouragement of that wick.
Okay, I'm not using that low as support
broken turn resistance. I'm looking at
that wick
and look at the reaction of it there.
And then watch the bodies do what I tell
you order flow should do. If it's
bearish, there should be no bodies
buried in the upper half of that wick.
So look at this line.
It closes right there, not higher.
Yes, it spread its wings a little bit
here and spread its wings a little bit
right here, but it's only doing two
things. It's delivering the errant price
action that would take us above that
wick consequent encroachment PD1
order block opening price change in
state delivery rise up to it and down
lower the bodies. I'm watching it stay
below that wick right there because it's
a premium array.
Find that like off find that in anything
else because it's not there. Goobbers
consolidation and it finally gives up
the ghost and goes lower hits the low
that was formed at 20% of the weekly
range which is TGIF. Now we're going to
see if we can get to halfway and aim
just about but just get out right before
because we want a low hanging fruit
objective. That's what I teach. Okay, I
can teach you precision, but you should
not try to get precise in the beginning.
Just get a big piece of the meat in the
middle. Okay, think about that big
drumstick at turkey time, Thanksgiving,
or if you like eating chicken legs.
The meat is just like right in the
middle of the bone. It's kind of like on
one side of the bone. Okay? And that's
how my PDRs work.
When you're bullish,
hold the the drumstick or the turkey
turkey leg or chicken leg where the side
that has the least meat, hold it up from
that end. So the biggest piece of meat
piece of meat is on the lower end of the
drumstick on the lower half of it. If
you're looking at it vertically in front
of you, if you're bearish, it's going to
go up and get the meat there and then go
lower. If you're bullish, reverse it.
The drumstick's meat's going to be on
the upper half. So when the market drops
down into the upper half of that
drumstick, it's going to consume that.
Eat it all up. You see that? Highest
production quality around here, baby. I
don't even have to push a button. Just
like that. See that? No special effects
required. I'm a oneman army here. I'm a
oneman show. Market crushkin. I can read
everything. Or or am I just making it
all up hindsight? Is that what it is?
Tell me.
market breaks lower and goes two
previous months high. I don't want to
hold for that. Even though I shared that
publicly in a tweet, I don't want to
hold for that because I could get it
wrong because Trump could go out there
and sneeze and say, "Hey,
they're coming in our borders right now.
Get down in your basement."
or
I just defeated everybody
and they said that they're going to open
up the straight of Hermoose and what's
going to happen markets.
So, I know that's likely to occur.
So, that's the new that's the new thing
we have to worry about in trading, the
interference, market manipulation.
his tweets aren't really causing that,
but they're using them as smokeOKC
screens to allow for those things to
occur. Okay. I I'm not sure if you knew
um what my MO is usually when I when I
start off and I start I'll say we're
going to do a short little video,
it turns into a space. Okay. Um that's
what we have here today. And I want you
to think about what I've covered so far
and what I'm going to say in the closing
marks.
Everything I'm teaching you here, if
it's the first time you're being exposed
to it, it just doesn't feel the same as
someone that's been with me for a while.
Those relative equal highs are not going
to get taken out if the things I
explained here are true.
If there's an inversion fair value gap
takes out a rejection block because the
bodies are the real volume. I don't need
that high to be taken out by the wick. I
don't need that. That's a gap for me.
And then it trading up into the gap if
that's what this wick is. Sure it is.
But is it going to do something after
that? So it's if it does this then it
better do what? It better go down and
respect this inversion fair value. It
does two candles then it goes lower
trades down the 20% of range the wick
here defends it says no I can't do
anything higher than that but I will go
back to Costco encroachment I'm sorry
but I will go up to change in the state
of delivery which is my order block
theory and then it trades lower
and here's previous month's high then
trades lower to 30% % of the weekly
range. That's TGAF. Now, in extremes, it
can go down to 40%. But it's extreme.
And I don't ever really force that too
much. And I've learned, especially in
the volatility we've been seeing in the
last recent years, if it's going to do
40%, it's probably going to go even
deeper than that. And that's just, you
know, something that most people aren't
going to be holding on to anyway. Uh 20%
is reasonable. It's tradable. 30% is,
yeah, it could happen. Um, I like to
look for half of 20 to 30. So that's
like 25%. And that would take us also an
agreement with around the previous
month's high. And you can see right here
at 1011,
do you only take trades or can you take
trades outside of the macro time? Well,
here's that answer. The macro suggests
that we're starting to spool. We want to
see it take out the low and we want to
see it gravitate down to 20% of the
weekly range and maybe maybe just maybe
get down into the previous week's range
and trade to 30% of the weekly range of
present week which we just closed. Okay?
In other words, basically this level,
this level, this level level, and that
level, they're all targets to reach for.
So, if I had like 10 contracts, I could
have took like something off below here,
something off right there, something off
at midpoint, and then something off
below that low, and something here, and
leave a partial on, maybe get something
below that maybe, and then get stopped
out probably for the rest. Okay,
I only had two contracts because of the
stop requirement.
Entry was right here.
And then
right there is the exit. And I just
realized that I don't have the little
thing toggled. But thankfully enough, I
shared a response to one of my students
that shows you the actual price. Okay.
So the price uh the fills are actually
shown on on X. Okay. And somebody was
asking me or saying something to the
effect that they've been trying to do
silver bullet and they're not seeing the
setups or whatever. And it just so
happens that I did one on Friday. And I
want you to take notice that this is
also showing those little arrows here.
And also include this on the the posted
tweet response to one of my students.
Um, if you're doing market replay, which
I'm not doing,
if you click this little thing up here
and toggle that and then hover your
little mouse over top of it, it'll tell
you if the market's open or if it's
closed. Obviously, it's Saturday the
15th of August, 2026. And at the present
time of me doing what I'm doing, um, it
is
12:29. So, I've been going for a while.
Okay. So, you're getting a Twitter space
about all this. You can't see this if
it's market replay. You'll also see
where this is at before you get to these
things here. And underneath it, there's
like these little control things for
market replay. That that's and you can't
see any executions.
Okay. if market replay was how you used
it. If you are able to do this, so
that's how you know I'm not using market
replay. Okay? I promise you it's not
necessary. Um I almost feel tempted this
week to just show you [laughter] the
difference between market replay and
actual live executions so that way you
can see it and finally put that to bed
because I know some people just think
it's just too good to be true. And
that's a wonderful compliment. Thank you
so very very much for that. But I
covered a lot of things here. I covered
how do I know when certain relative
equal highs or lows are not going to be
traded to because they're guarded
liquidity. Okay. And I'm looking for
very specific things. I talked about,
you know, entering outside of the macro.
Well, in this case, I needed some more
confirmation. Things are going to be
there. So, if the macro is delivering
and so in so close approximity to a PDA
rate, I would trade inside the macro
time. I'm only one minute after.
There's nothing wrong with that. There's
nothing wrong with trading this right
here,
right there. Why? Because that's an
order block, a change in state of
delivery. That's, you know, that's
outside of the macro. What's wrong with
that? That could be a pyramided entry if
I felt inclined to build a position
larger. But these these executions are
two contracts in, two contracts out. And
I was aiming for half of 20 to 30% of
the weekly range. Okay? So, you have to
know your extraction point. You have to
know how the smart money is going to
leave the marketplace. And that's them
leaving it up here, exiting their longs,
distributing it, distributing it,
distributing it, and then it rolls down
and does the things I teach on my video,
all for free. It's a labor of love,
baby. Hope you enjoyed this. Hope you
found something insightful in it. Until
I talk to you next time, Lord willing, I
don't know when it's going to be. Enjoy
your weekend. Be safe.